save the world
the truth is Walter has the ultimate
trump card if we ever write anything
that annoys him he will delete our
endemics story banana genesis of it is
for 25 years now ever on a company that
I refer to as a home for the mentally
enabled its people with high IQ and a
little EQ we're trying to make them
functional in society and make them
useful and finding geniuses is hard 150
IQ is Irina mom has one to ten thousand
people so what we did was we figured
wonderful thing to find us what if we
type for awareness and people saw
themselves on the show and
and reached out to us so far which is we
can understand now it's sort of exciting
is to see somebody else's progression no
these are playing a real life character
all these interesting things that was
talking about right now so there's so
much mileage in what the show committee
and also the character because you're
joining in my supposed the beginning
about reintroduction to into comparators
the steps to becoming where water is
right now is it's a very interesting
challenge as an actor comes in as me for
about three days I feel it's very
important to serve a story instead of
water to spend as much time I suppose
getting into talking about the past in
Ireland when you get up to have a moment
where your brains out and how you would
react to sort of learned behavior I
suppose is what what my understand is
how you administer an you behave with
other people and the challenges to do
that but I've spent a lot of time
talking to Walter as much time as
well that car changed when they got to
that part of his grant not departing but
a big car everything woman well I mean
first of all I think that playing a
character that was so different from
something it didn't smash she's a young
mother sitting over a child on her own
is something so different and then all
the action elements that we have in this
show and you know I think that we talk
about so much that we love about the
show is that it has so much heart and
it's funny and there's there's these
moments of high action so for me when I
was reading is correct I just thought
wow this is something so different and
something new for me to try and you'll
go to shelter man her I didn't kill
we have stunts in when we didn't move
nearly how the Hydra was a dozen second
but all they're like crazy stuff for the
producers of the show
it's going to be action-adventure much
of it's going to be character
development pretty much taken together
the shirts about the characters who had
Danny today the action and the
adventures each week and there will be
an adventure and a problem and a
conundrum that eats this incredible team
as to attack each week but that only
exists to affect and reflect on this
incredible team of characters it's a
character driven show with that being
said the opportunity mates are saying to
do that this idea that the higher the FQ
the lower the EQ is such initiative
problem for us and I was I think one of
the things that got so drawn to this
from the beginning that the things that
we take for granted as being normal
everyday tasks are impossible for these
geniuses and the things that we would
think are impossible are normal everyday
tasks for them and so watching them and
learn to raise their emotional
intelligence and learn to adapt to the
world I think makes them other dogs that
everybody can root for so in many ways
the action would be nothing without that
as the beating heart of the show that
being said the action will continue to
be what it was in the prior that you all
like now
you know that's a plan
to the characters like especially the
team scorpion the backstories we saw
some flash better we will absolutely
getting into their backstories and I
think you know we're gonna get to know
these people as well as we can I think
of everything all the again on the
action stuff and all the all the
adventures that they're going into are
going to reflect on every bit of their
personality and you know I would say one
of the most interesting things about
Walters world and the real world is
these are incredibly gifted people on
one hand and then on the other hand they
are you know they can be extraordinarily
awkward so moving forward in you know in
sort of the adventures of what we're
doing and in character to build on that
stuff is putting these people in a
situations where they're absolutely
perfect and then also putting them into
situations where they're for Brenda Slee
bad so that's sort of fun you know the
fun of the adventure stuff
relationships bringing her in using her
to deal with the pieces and you know
these guys are like it's like hurting a
group of puppies in the right direction
and dangle it out there say hey and I'm
really interested to see what the
relationship goes with Walter Elias is
character and there's a lot of conflict
we snatched him from his farm in Ireland
unbeknownst to us he was as you saw the
hacker you know
so it's been a lot of fun there the cool
thing about mr. Patrick he's so modest
he would never say this but real life is
following art a little bit in in the
show he's becomes a father figure to
these characters and on set Robert is
helping these actors we have a huge
group of actors and they're all so
talented but when you're working with
some of the Robert Patrick it's very
easy to turn to him and look up to him
he's been so successful and Robert will
openly give advice and incredibly
generous with him and everyone who goes
out
I'm gonna go to perverts are real quick
because I did get a lot of questions on
Twitter about where Paige and Walter's
relationship is going to be going what
can you say about that for me saying the
idea of having a connection to humanity
in a census is the bridge between the
humanity and the problems that they saw
on what Roberts character what page fill
with Scorpio and so that's going to be a
complicated relationship on the one hand
I think you rely on someone like that
and also you can resent the idea that
you have to realize something like that
and so there it's not simply friendships
here's the idea that these characters
know that they're doing good together
but meeting people it's difficult I
think that's part of I think what we've
learned from sort of figuring out these
shows that when you're so smart you
maybe you don't need anybody we all need
each other and so the idea of all these
characters meeting each other is both
what they wanted what
I said that access Twitter laughing
Walter the character doesn't seem too
much of the singing guy but we got food
sang that is up there like with an egg
like is there ever going to be any
musical element to the show who knows
okay so do you have any questions out
there yeah
nice cameo right away my question is
around me like financials of the show
so are you funding the show or are you
getting kickbacks or right
we've always talked about something that
down the line that there could be
somebody who was you know is you know
what it's done in his world is a black
hat actor who could be you know somebody
who's definitely in that loss of
something to talk good idea the answer
is real life right yet
hi my name is Teresa I'm a teacher in
Ohio and I was wondering if you have any
advice for teachers on how to recognize
the genius and students versus sometimes
seeing them as Katherine did her son at
first season with disabled and will that
come out in the show address many people
don't understand what IQ means they over
here's the term genius
I think they understand that world a
little better I know for myself teachers
used to complain that I was slow it's
for every one question another kid would
ask I had ten questions I think that
this show will raise awareness and a
better understanding of why these folks
are the way they are why their internal
sounding board was broken and why soft
skills and the social skills are cut out
advice for teachers unfortunately and
all kids are not the same that can't be
taught the same way the can't be treated
the same way
I think just recognizing that I'm
telling them if you know how I keep
kidded it means living one in 10,000 so
the whole school disagrees with them was
the board a 50% chance he's right and
they're wrong
you'll also only find two people in his
life but the truly empathize whether so
it's it's a lonely place of dirty hi my
name is Anthony first I want to say that
Patrick like being in front of Robert
Patrick was going down suddenly like 17
years old watching g-tube with the
person
are you sure
I shall never move
my questions forget
I follow your music I love your music so
he's wondering what's up I feel like
from that did something with an
action-packed like this well I'm really
gonna do it to be annoying it's just
like it's very what we enjoy
when a foot of water will kill us we
talked about that a lot in the early
stages the first time I sat down with
Walter the first day we ever met within
a few minutes I felt that this shows
hook was being one in one point four
nine seven billion is lonely next with
Walter Ennis there's three people in the
world I've never scored high on an IQ
test and Walter I'm sitting next to
number four we don't want to make one of
those we do it's it's difficult it's
challenging Walter has described it
sometimes in ways that makes it feel
like a disability so at no point it will
our attention ever be to mock or make
fun of there might be humor and the
inability to fit in or to adjust but how
many geniuses there are in this room
other than wall
but all of us have probably felt that
way we lacked ourselves sometimes we
never want to take it further than that